the Biden Administration is considering
a nationwide ban on new gas stoves
citing harmful pollution release that
can cause health and respiratory
challenges one study found it was the
cause of 12 percent of childhood asthma
cases in the U.S but there's a fierce
backlash gas stoves are already in 40
percent of American households and
Democratic senator Joe manchin is
cooking up some outrage quote this is a
recipe for disaster the federal
government has no business telling
American families how to cook their
dinner
I go to my colleague here to my right
judge you seem to be hurraying him on
with that comment absolutely I'm a cook
no he's going to tell me I can't cook
with gas first of all any good cooks
with gas it's an immediate up down low
high you know and I tried to cook with
an electric stove in Florida I know and
and what I did was I just can't cook
with it first of all it's the ultimate
Nanny steak the same Nanny state that
says you can't drink 32 ounces of a soda
drink is not good for you well who don't
want you to tell me that I don't need
you to tell me that and the other thing
is you know why does everything have to
be regulated you want to come into my
kitchen and what are you going to do now
are you going to like knock the doors
down to see if I really have a gas stove
and by the way the electric stoves are
more expensive especially if you don't
have one and then to cook on it
electricity is so much more expensive so
all the way around I think it's
ridiculous and by the way this isn't
about about the environment it's about
our health I'll take care of my health
thank you what did you cook in Florida
the Gabba goal I never cooked
you guys see what are your thoughts
about this this is an attack on natural
gas not gas stoves you know who funded
the study the Rocky Mountain Institute
what do they do they're trying to
transform the global Energy System to a
security clean prosperous zero carbon
see it's not about the asthma they just
put that little thing in there this is
about getting rid of natural gas
follow the money Harold Dana as You
Follow the money you come up with the
same electric stoves are electric ranges
are much more likely to have house fires
than gas ranges and they if they do the
death rate is 3.5 percent higher
um with that so would you rather have
asthma or die
this comes out on the same day that we
find out that the ozone layer is you
know like not a problem so like people
like at the Rocky Mountain Institute
they just want you to live in constant
fear of climate change because it funds
their studies and their lifestyle right
Yes exclamation mark how do you feel
about this well obviously the gas stove
is bad for the environment but my
toaster is racist
have you ever checked the little ratings
down there it's clear black toast is
wrong and you have to have a nice shade
it's just disgusting every time I walk
into my kitchen that toaster is just
deeply offending me and I don't know
what to do but it's just like it women
and minorities are hurt hardest by
racist toasters that's the headline in
the New York Times here's the secret
everything in life is bad for you you
can die from drinking too much water
it's called drowning
oh that was good thank you you're
welcome before they ban this they should
think about maybe getting people help
them get people afford more ventilation
in there they're doing it in New York
City you know that they've banned
electric stoves here any new apartment
building going up it has to be electric
not gas you know what if I have a good
vent system what's it to them I want to
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now